you
hello everyone how's everybody today I
hope you're doing fine just wanted to go
over a little bit of my discussion with
jfg the other day I was on his program
again known as the public space and I
discussed specifically the Rope model of
light not only a light really of light
the atom gravity electromagnetism in
general magnetic attraction electricity
I covered those four or five subjects
specifically and idea was to argue that
as a minimum as a minimum the Rope
should be considered side by side with
the other two options that we have today
which is the wave and a particle people
say that light is a flow of particles a
series of particles you know bullets one
right after another and others say it's
a wave some say it's of nothing others
say it's of the ether and after 400
years we have a new proposal and that's
the rope model and what are we saying
we're saying that rope is mediate light
is mediated by a rope it doesn't go up
and down
it's the torsion 3d torsion so we have
the 2d wave up and down we have the I
guess longitudinal particles that's the
way they always draw them you know
longitudinal waves kind of you know just
there bear faction and compression of
particles back and forth like sound and
but they say it's a transverse wave so
you figured out how they can reconcile
those two notions and then you have the
3d torsion so we can say one
longitudinal particles particle waves
or train of particles 2d is the
transverse wave up and down you know
standing wave and then we have the 3d
portion of a rope and I showed that you
know at least the Rope as it relates to
light can at least answer speed why lyta
so fast why light is a constant why
light travels so straight top taut rope
the torsion never gets lost never goes
never curves or anything always go
straight along the ropes and well
several properties of light and I also
showed even though I didn't dwell too
much on that the other proposals wave
and particle they don't meet some of the
minimum requirements that we need to
cover the specification of light light
has already been known for the last 200
years to have certain properties and
neither the transverse wave nor the flow
of particles model neither of those two
really you know explains or justifies
many of the properties of light the rope
justifies them all but even if you
disagree you may say well you know I
think that the standing wave does mimic
certain properties the particles
simulate some other properties fine as a
minimum the Rope should be considered
side by side as a as a candidate for as
a mediator for light and now that was
the main point that I was trying to make
not only did I cover the light I covered
also the atom and when I look at a
little bit of the atom today
relates to that discussion in general
and today I put up a video showing the
[Music]
history you know how the atom the notion
of the atom of this unseen little thing
that makes up everything how would
progress through the ages and some of
you saw the video but all I'm gonna go
through it real quickly just to put
everybody in the same on the same page
in the same mind frame and here it is we
start with Lucifer's and Democritus
right and Democritus essentially came up
with the ball not that one there that's
today's atom he came up with a ball that
one okay so the indivisible ball in fact
the word atom means indivisible okay and
by the way I put the Parthenon there but
Socrates was not a guy that lived in
Athens but the building looked huge so I
thought I'd serve as a little bit of
background there anyways about 400 BC
him and his tutor I guess knew suppose
they came up with this notion that there
is some kind of indivisible entity out
there they called it the atom that's the
word we have today and we thought for
the next 2,000 years that actually it
was an indivisible that everything was
made of these little stones these
brownstones invisible round stones and
that's what we dealt with all the way to
the 19th century 19th century we have
mr. Dalton specifically and he came up
with this you can call it out periodic
table 1827 he had an earlier one in 1808
they say he stole the idea from William
Higgins
an Irish guy chemist who either sued him
or at least challenged him and said that
he was plagiarized by by Dalton anyways
this was the model again you can see
there still
with spheres okay nothing changed from
the days of the Greeks and essentially
you know we lasted well you know then
you have Mendeleev he comes a little
after mid-century 1870s in fact he
started by 1863 was his first periodic
table and the second one came out 1871 a
more complete one based on the atomic
weights and he published in Russian and
so he didn't get a lot of coverage but
then he also published in German that's
where he got a little more well known
you know by the way am I getting feed
you mean back the word is their problem
with sound again
Martin is there a problem with the sound
again please let me know
okay okay so you had a problem on your
side okay yeah okay as long as you can
hear me but please let me know if
there's something with a sound I think
I'm next time I'm gonna try to use a
different computer okay I'm gonna change
the computer see if that does anything
but anyways let me continue where was I
Dalton he came up with these really he
had the same spheres that as his
predecessors so they just realized that
every atom has a different sphere and
you can see the little drawings here for
Dalton you know it's like he just put
little signs in them he didn't
understand he just says they're all
spheres but somehow I got to distinguish
them and he just drew these symbols to
distinguish one particle from another
okay and it would not be until until
Mendeleev after mid 19th century that he
comes up with a periodic table and until
he published in German he was not really
well known but after that his table was
accepted worldwide by chemists and
physicists and it was based on atomic
weights and that's the table we have
today much more improvement with more
elements that have been found since then
and well you know that's that's the rest
is history as they say okay okay
beginning of the 20th century we have
mr. JJ Thompson and he had the plum
pudding model here we have a fluid
inside a ball that's how he envisioned
it that's how he described it he says
there's he thought it was like a fluid
and he's got that and it's a positive
fluid for some reason and he's got these
negative charges just floating in there
okay same year in 1904 we have mr. Hanh
pyro Nagaoka and he comes up with the
Saturnian model which is pretty much
like if you come to think of it right
it's pretty much like the planetary
model so it's not like you know the
people in the West
came up with a planetary model first
this is in some way a planetary model
except that what Nagaoka was saying was
that you know all these negative charges
the orbited around a plane so he
imagined it like Saturn that's why it's
called the Saturnian model and this is
gonna come in somewhat handy to mr. de
Broglie in 1924 when he comes up with
his wave that the electron is a wave
that surrounds the the middle of the
proton or the middle of the nucleus and
like a hula hoop and you can see that
where he could have gotten the idea you
probably got it
also from Nagaoka okay so this model was
still around in those days it's just not
so much so famous in the West okay it's
not so well-known here rather Ford and
his team together with Marsden and
Geiger guy who invented the Geiger
counter they developed in 1911 by 1911
they started like in 1908 they developed
this atom which is the same thing as
Nagaoka proposed except that the
electron does not orbit in a given plane
like the rings of Saturn but instead it
just goes all over the place okay and
Niels Bohr then a couple years later who
was working also at the same lab as
Rutherford he comes up with his famous
atom in which he explains why the
essentially he explains what is known as
quantum jump or quantum leap which is
that the electron falls to a lower
energy level and rises to an energy
level and by doing so by going back and
forth within these two levels it
releases and absorbs packets of energy
the packets of energy that were
discovered a few years or early
or theorized a few years earlier by Max
Planck actually 1900 turn of the century
he said that light comes in discrete
packets and so you know essentially
Niels Bohr incorporated that notion
within his model and by the way Einstein
also did incorporated in his analysis of
the photoelectric effect you know that
quantum became very famous because
according to all these people could
explain a lot of things but it forced
them to assume that light really
consisted or came in packages in bundles
in discrete stones okay
so to speak okay we have 1924 we have
mr. Lewis de Broglie and he comes up
with his wave model he says the electron
is really a wave I guess he imagined it
as a 2-dimensional way because you know
we cannot imagine what will come later
which is the shell which is the cloud
model so this one is a 2d wave he just
described mathematically and essentially
the electron bead because he can't get
rid of the bead the bead jumps from one
energy level to another which is what
Bohr had already said but he says you
know I Canton the electrons really
spread out it's kind of like it's not a
little ball but it's it's really the
wave itself it's a wave that goes in
integral or in integers around the you
know the atom there's no there's no half
integer you don't get ten waves and a
half or ten what is it
ten yeah I guess you call them waves
each one of those lumps there or two of
them I guess or would be half yeah from
the top of one to the bottom of the
other that's what it would be well one
of those will caught a wave and you need
to have integer numbers of them
you can have ten you can have eleven but
you can't have ten and a half
that's what Louis de Broglie calculated
and you came up with the equation got a
noble four up for it right and so that's
the model he that was accepted into that
point regarding the electron and the
last one to come out and the one we use
today and it's Schrodinger's and borns
cloud model they're saying well it's not
really a particle it's not really a way
of what it is it's a cloud that
encapsulate s-- the nucleus when it
shrinks and expands it releases energy
that's what those those lightning bolts
are okay going out of there and you
should have some a couple coming in as
well because it absorbs and emits okay
and so this is this the model that we
had and that we have today this is the
model that you're taught at the high
levels of the University as you can see
and nobody likes to illustrate it
because they don't believe that this is
correct either in fact they don't use
this model and that's important to note
you know they don't really use the born
model I'll call it the born or the
strode in your model they don't use it
because when you explain electricity
when you explain ionization you know
then you go back to the planetary model
to Bohr's or brother forked model where
you have the nucleus and the little bead
and the bead goes from atom dad and
that's electricity for you and if you
pull the bead from the atom you've got
ionization you know there's no mention
of orbitals of clouds of shells at that
point in that context the shell is
brought in when you're doing covalent
bonding you know to two atoms come
together and depending on which atoms
right you can have ionic bonding you
have metallic bonding you have hydrogen
bonding you've got all these different
types of bonding covalent bonding is the
merging of shells so they get rid of the
bead and they said oh yeah
physically what's happening is the
shells merged but there are no shells
see the shells is a region a region
where you can find the electron be we
get rid of the bead now we only have the
region now the regions are coming
together now we refine the regions we're
saying the region is now a shell and
we're gonna get two shells together
merge them you know blend them together
that's what they're saying so yeah
that's that's the idea that we have
today what those bill gave you come up
with where I'm saying that you know
these people have been mistaken all
these years that's what we have we have
our dear Adam here you shown how its
constructed we're gonna construct a
proton star and the electron shell which
encapsulate sit it pumps there and
creates light and here's how it's
constructed you have the electric thread
going through the middle and you have
the magnetic gland thread going around
and an electric magnetic are just to
stick with convention and what happens
you have that model there where one
encapsulate s' the other and when it
when it pumps back and forth right it
crew it towards the rope and by torquing
the rope what we're doing is essentially
sending light to you know to the rest of
the universe okay
and just in case something some people
sometimes want to see it here's how an
atom we have an atom here we'll call it
a hydrogen atom just approaching another
hydrogen atom maybe they're going to
convert it into hydrogen gas h2 and what
we have is they're pumping each other
right and then what it does is it slides
along the rope okay it's the kind of one
is gonna slide along the rope and it's
gonna eat links as it goes forward and
release links behind it and that's when
I say you know that an atom slides like
a beat on an abacus that's what I mean
that's that's the mechanism there okay
okay
so
that gives you an overview of the atom
and that's the overview I wanted to give
jfg on Wednesday when I talked about it
he raised the question and it's a
question that a lot of people ask
themselves and it's got to do with just
in case checking to see if the sound is
okay
it's got to do with what is known as
light on light and the issue has to do
with whether the ropes in the case of
light I'm light as it relates to ropes
whether the ropes cross each other or
not because you know people immediately
ask well you know so many ropes in the
universe every iron is interconnected by
ropes do these ropes go through each
other at any point and I caught the
tangling issue it's known in official
circles as light on light either either
term is essentially a synonym it relates
to this problem and all I can tell you
it's the number one problem the only
problem we need to solve it's the only
problem is it's a headache of a problem
believe me I spent two years on it and
I'm not bragging I'm just giving you a
fact it's it's a monster and so the
question is what kind of answers do we
have for this then I taught aft I gave
him the answer I gave him really I said
I had a series of answers three or four
and I want to go through them because
you know I want people don't understand
what the answer is
okay okay here goes let's let's here's
the first argument the first argument
these are the arguments one is that it's
a premature question premature question
and you might say bill what the hell do
you mean by that what do you mean it's a
premature question yeah it's a premature
question because I presented with jfg
but it can occur with anyone out there
you explained the theories
look this is the model that I'm gonna
use and these are the theories this is
how I explain magnetism this is how I
explain like this is how I explain
gravity etcetera etcetera and the
workings of the atomists
as I just showed you a second ago how
the atom is constructed how it pumps
what is known as you know quantum jump
it's a different model and we have a
balloon going back and forth torquing
the rope like those along the rope to
another atom so once you explain that
the person says well you got all these
ropes you know what are they made out of
they say answer so that one is easy it's
made out of two threads to twenty
threads so that's an easy question and
and that takes them off-guard they say
well what are the threads named they
want to continue you know so I have a
lot of fun with that one but let's let's
get back to this one the the tangling
issue the light unlight issue okay the
first one is that the first answer to
that question is a premature question
why because here I've showed you that
light that the Rope can simulate
magnetism and let me show that just real
quickly just a second here do I get the
thing here here it is this is what we
got have to explain we have to explain
those patterns that the magnetic field
so called magnetic field means around a
magnet and we know about these patterns
because we drop iron filings around them
and they we know that the flow of the
lines of force moves like you're seeing
there you're seeing that it goes in on
the inside where it goes in that's the
south side and where it goes out is the
north side okay and we have to explain
these patterns and rope model explains
them says look one of the threats comes
loose goes around the atom okay and
through the center and out the other end
that's what's happening with a thread so
we have to look at the thread as a
physical entity it goes through the
center and then how does it produce
attraction here you'll see it in the
next
little piece here at the bottom you see
how they latch on the left and how they
push each other away on the right so we
do have a mechanism now it doesn't mean
you have to buy this mechanism what I'm
saying is you know we we have a
mechanism for showing love with the
thread with a rope one of the threats
comes loose or two threats can do it
doesn't matter really matter and it goes
around the magnet and by doing so first
we can explain the patterns left on iron
filings second we can explain how they
push each other way or if they both go
in the same direction
you know here it comes down here it goes
up we can explain attraction so we have
a mechanism you don't have to agree but
we do have a mechanism you know and so
that's the important part we have a
mechanism with a rope we also can
explain light we're saying okay how
about light okay how do we explain light
here we have the checklist of light
which I showed give me a second here so
I get this thing up there here's the
checklist of light any entity that has
to simulate night must meet these
specifications it has to be a body it
has to be an object you can't say it's
the waving of nothing as quantum says
today it has to start at the atom you
know light does start at an atom fact I
think I have something to show for that
[Music]
yeah here it is just for those who
because J of T is asked that question
does it start at an atom here it is yeah
the atom pumps back and forth and
generates in in the case of quantum
mechanics those photons those balls
which travel outwards okay so the
Quantum Jumping generates light and and
that means that light starts at an atom
light does not get generated in heaven
by God it gets generated by the pumping
of the atom somehow you know the little
bead electron bead goes back and forth
somehow
it's energy and that energy is light
okay it's tribal in whatever we propose
for light has to travel right to the
linearity or in my case stretches
straight it has to travel very fast and
you have to show why it travels at
300,000 kilometers per second why it's a
constant and it has to meet all the wave
properties it's gotta have you know and
should oscillate around an axis because
that's what the electromagnetic wave the
transverse wave does Faraday Maxwell
laws the magnetic field generates the
electric field and vice versa they both
travel perpendicular to each other and
then it has to have the features that
include frequency wave length and
amplitude well right there and then this
these wave properties eliminate the
particle you can't have particles okay
because particles cannot explain why
goes up and down frequency wave they
cannot explain any of these features if
anything because maybe you can make a
case the ones on the left but not the
ones on the right so so you know does
the rope answer these questions and the
answer is yes the Rope is straight it's
pulled tight you know it's fast in fact
I made a case that here's the comparison
we have the transverse wave that's used
by mathematical physics we which is the
snail there we have the turtle which is
the longitudinal wave which is always
compared against it and what these
people forget is the torsion wave in
other words if you have a torsion along
a rope
it not only travels much faster than the
other two in fact the fastest thing
known to man but it travels in both
directions and it travels straight it
can do it otherwise because the rope is
pulled taut so you know again it doesn't
mean you have to agree with any of this
all I'm saying is that the rope has an
explanation has a justification for some
of these properties it can do magnetism
to magnets we can show
that it can show some of the properties
of light in fact all of them as far as
I'm concerned I showed electricity I'm
not gonna go to the details here I
showed gravity you know you have let's
see if I can show just the picture that
summarizes I think it's this one well
this one here so here's gravity for you
with ropes we have an elephant falling
to earth and the ropes every rope is
tight
remember it's pulled tight so all the
ropes are straight at all porn at all
moments it never does it Bend and here
you have its interconnected gross versus
discrete particles although atoms are
interconnected from one object to
another as one object approaches another
the ROS fan out okay that's what that's
the mechanism and so when the elephant
falls to earth you can see that more and
more ropes fan out and tug or act
independently okay once again you do not
have to agree with any of this all I'm
saying is whether oh we can do light
with a rope we can do magnetism with a
rope we can do gravity electricity the
atom you know so with just this model we
can do all these things the we meet the
fundamental requirements of each one of
these we meet the specifications and if
that's the case the argument again is
you know as a minimum it should be
considered side by side with the party
going by the way that's all I'm saying
I think it deserves an attention from
that point of view and so it's a
premature question asked what is the
rope made out of or what does the road
cross do do ropes tangled or do they
cross each other etc if the rope doesn't
qualify the rope does not answer light
the Rope does not answer magnetism if
you believe that the Rope does not
answer gravity and we don't need to get
to that other step see first we have to
answer
these other questions does the rope
explain the mechanism of attraction the
magnetism does it explain to men the
attraction
according to gravity does it explain the
properties of light if you say it
doesn't then I'm not even gonna meet I
don't even need to answer the question
of you know what is the Rope made out of
does it stretch from here to on dromeda
from one atom here to an atom there do
they cross each other those are
irrelevant questions because you've
already decided that it does not answer
the mechanisms that we know for light
gravity magnetic attraction electricity
that's the purpose of the Rope the Rope
is is going to be used to answer these
questions and if you're saying that you
don't agree then what's the point of
asking if ropes go through each other
okay so it's a pretty mature question in
that sense you either buy into the rope
and then ask these questions but first
you got to concede that they that the
rope does explain the mechanism and if
so that means that should be treated
side by side with a particle in the wave
period whether you like it or not
now once you concede that then then we
can talk about you know properties of
the rope whether it crosses the first
question does it explain mechanisms
that's the first question must be
answered in that sense any question
outside of that is premature okay so
that's the first one here's the second
one if we reject the rope we got to go
back to one
we got a classical whichever in other
words we got to go back and say okay
we're not gonna accept the rope we got
to go back to particles we got to go
back to waves that's all we got because
in the last 400 years we've only had a
bone II had three three proposals on the
table now some people say well that's
not true
we have Fortis says we have ether you
know we have all these goodies out there
the field you know and you know again
these are not objects and it takes a
long time for people to understand it
plasma you know electricity these these
are not physical objects and it takes
two years for these people to understand
that you got a you got a really talk to
them a lot for in the guy to put some
interest they think you're just doing
semantics whether I'm going back on jf
G's show not this week I I don't know
I have no new schedule with him he might
call me back
Martin so I don't know as far as today's
concern I don't know I don't have any
plans from that angle okay anyways the
point here is that the second issue we
must answer is that lost a little bit
here let me put it back yeah that if we
don't if we don't do the rope if we
don't accept the road we got to go back
to particles and that's a that's a
problem that's a problem because
particles don't answer any question and
one of the main questions that particles
don't answer is is this one here the one
that troubles people so much let's see
if I can find it here well here here's
the three models these are the three
models proposed we have the standing
wave or transverse wave whichever one
you want there you have the discrete
photons particles corpuscles and we have
the torsion those are the three okay and
there are no other proposals on the
table so we don't take the road we got
to go back to one of those and and what
what can it answer oh here's where I
think where I wanted the second one had
a third one there quantum superposition
decoherence see the the issue we've got
here is that quantum also
uses it has a tangling problem or has a
has a problem with light on light and
the issue is that the they caught
superposition that two particles can be
at the same place at the same time and
so people say well bill through the
ropes tangle and I answer well why did
you ask that question to the quantum
mechanics guys I mean when they say
superposition they're saying two
particles occupy the same space and they
don't bump each other out like normal
things you're in the macro world do and
you never ask the question they just
said superposition you said Aloha or
they say something worse to explain the
slit experiment they say the particle
can be at two places at once it's that
that the particle breaks up into the
same particle is at two places at once
no nobody asked these questions and it
doesn't affect and even everybody's okay
with all this stuff so we've got a
problem we've got a problem when people
I asked the question from the robe they
want to you know put the rope on trial
and say oh I'm gonna question you to
death
why don't you question quantum mechanics
first because they have a tangling issue
also they just caught superposition and
you never called it out to them you
never call their bluff it's like oh yeah
superposition Oh decoherence you know
part of gonna be a two places one no
problem you know at least the Rope
doesn't say that the rope could be at
two places at once but you know the
tangling issue is a valid issue again I
broke my head two years on it I know how
oh I'm an expert on that let me tell you
I broke my head on the tangling issue
but before we answer that question let's
tackle quantum let's make sure quantum
dies so we don't go back to quantum okay
so first let's talk about superposition
let's talk about the coherence and then
we'll then we'll answer all you the
questions you want about the rope let's
make sure quantum dies if quantum can't
answer it I don't have to answer it
that's that's what I can say
what I can argue first you know fix the
official version of the atom first fix
the official version of light of
magnetism of electricity
first let's destroy that so we don't go
bad let's burn that bridge so we don't
cross backwards okay okay what's the
another argument another argument is
that in order to which I mentioned the
jfg is that in order to X to understand
an explanation you must set the
foundations
you must plant the foundations of
physics you must make sure that people
understand the language of physics
understand what physics is about and
like I told them the first thing is that
you need to establish or though you know
you can't do physics without an object
imagine you know you raise everything
out of the universe
God comes in just wipes everything out
leaves nothing whatever nothing means to
you there's nothing there okay
what's happening what do you observe you
what experiments can you do with nothing
obviously you need to have something
we'll call those somethings objects okay
we'll call them objects so you need an
object to do physics you can't do
physics without objects and if that's
the case that's the case you know you
need to define the word object you need
to know what an object is for the
purposes of physics and nobody has done
some of the last ten thousand years not
a single book of physics but begins by
defining the word object or telling us
the importance that you can't do physics
without object because if they would
start with that then people would
understand why it's important but people
don't even understand how important it
is to define the word object and why you
need to define the word object and
that's that the only word you need to
define distance location
what is motion what what do we mean by
exist this is the science of existence
so you need to define these terms so
that you set the foundations for for
physics and people want to skip all that
and they say what I want to deal with
Brammer or semantics I want to go I want
to do physics
no you need to eat your soup okay
become strong so you can't you can't do
physics unless you understand the
language unless you understand what the
purpose of physics is and you can't you
know people want to go to college and
talk about you know how the ropes avoid
tangling and and they don't want to go
through kindergarten to learn the
foundations that's the issue because
they say well that's not fizzy that's
grammar that's semantics now you need to
and so if you decide you need to in
order to understand my answer you know
like I gave them the example of the word
touch before ropes can cut across each
other you know I didn't the example I
like that example because you got a rope
right and you have a pair of scissors
you're gonna cut through them before you
can cut the rope you need to touch the
rope the blades need to touch the rope
and so the question is what do we mean
by touch what kind of question is that
everybody knows what touch means well
yeah in an ordinary speech we say we
touch the table but in scientific
language in physics you need to define
what the word touch is because it's
gonna make or break your theory did the
scissor touch the pair of scissors touch
you know the the rope before it cut
across and you know again we have that
issue where touch means you know zero
distance between two objects but zero
distance means they convert into one
object and that destroys the definition
of touch which requires two objects and
distance and so we you know as long as
you got space between the two fingers
they haven't touched each other
I still haven't touched them because
there's always space between the two
fingers you know the atoms did not blend
you know proton did not come against
proton in there and so we go back to the
word touch and all I'm saying is you
know you need to define these terms
before before you can deal with issues
like
does a rope avoid hanging does it cut
across what does a rope do there's a lot
of issues to be resolved this is not a
simple issue question okay and again
before you know I one of the things I
have is that I don't deal with the
tangling issue on the internet I've said
that times in the past I say it one more
time officially I do not answer
questions regarding touch regarding
tangling or touch relief for that matter
but I don't deal with the issue of
tangling with light on light because 99%
of people out there they don't have the
right language to understand physics we
got bigger problem or basic problems
these people want this high level
question answered this is the problem
and so they get it all wrong they always
get it wrong and I'm just wasting my
time trying to explain it to them so I
don't do that what I'm saying is you
want to know whether they afford tanging
whether they tango where they go through
each other or not chapter 7 of my book
and they say oh yeah that's just a way
of selling your book that's not the
point the point I'm trying to make is
the I have an answer I've written it
down it's published it's there okay the
answer is there I'm not gonna deal with
it on the internet because people don't
have the right language to understand my
answer okay you need to eat a lot of
soup you need to really get a lot of
words really deep in your head to
understand the language first so that
you can understand the question and the
answer okay so there's a lot involved
with the tangling light on light issue
okay and among those issues one of the
very important issues is whether light
touches light you have two lasers okay
you point them at each other do the
photons waves whatever ricochet bounce
and come apart so we have
couple studies one of them is by mr.
Burke
okay and his team came up with this
paper okay positon positron production
and multiple multi photon light by light
scattering okay and according to mr.
Burke
yeah particles of light bounce off each
other I says the positrons are
interpreted as rising arising from a
two-step process in which laser photons
are back scattered laser photons are
back scatter they bounce off each other
and by the electron being followed by a
collision between high-energy photon and
several laser photons to produce an
electron-positron pair
okay later on he uses the term virtual
photon to refer to that you know so he
virtual photon enters his discussion and
when you look at some of these key terms
like the Y's occur
Williams approximation you find out that
you know in that case the electron
carries a whole bunch of virtual photons
in a knapsack and unload somewhat will
so that the mathematician doesn't have
to justify that essentially you got
infinite photons there and so they don't
have to count them or anything you don't
have to worry about that and then a
virtual photon is you look it up and
it's a particle like abstraction which
facilitates understanding of
calculations the term is rather loose
and vaguely defined they appear in
calculations but never has indexes to
the scattering matrix they never appear
as the observable inputs or outputs of
the physical process be and model their
existence is questionable however the
term is useful in informal casual
conversation or in rendering concepts
into layman's terms so that's what a
virtual photon or particle is so here we
have mr. Birk and he writes in a
scientific paper allegedly and he's
using words terms virtual photons that's
how he explains it which is from
ordinary
speech which is an abstraction which
should be would not be included under
scientific language and it turns out he
claims that photons bounce off each
other when you push him against the
ropes he said well they're virtual
photon where is the virtual photons
well I greeted it with over on my magic
wand so so that's the story for the
virtual Photon
so the so the bottom-line do photons
really bounce off each other I mean here
you have it see if I can put a little
video to show you what the problem is
here you have two sprays okay and again
the question goes to light on light
whether photons bounce off each other
and the questions do particles of light
collide
well Bert says they do but he uses the
the virtual photon to explain it now we
know that macro particles like in that
spray there
we know those bounce off each other you
just you don't have to take my word for
it just take your shower head and put it
against another shower head and you'll
see that some of the particles bounce
off each other you know if you point
them fast enough they'll bounce and
they'll splatter and and you know
they'll hit each other because there's
something there okay but when you do
that with two lasers you don't see the
little photons bouncing off and what
Burt tried to do here was show us that
yeah indeed they do bounce off each
other okay they bounce off each other
Reiko Shan and go backwards and so this
this issue is quite fascinating because
we have mr. Rutherford and he'd ran an
experiment in 1911 and it went something
like this
he threw alpha particles at a gold thin
gold foil right and the particles went
through most of them but one of them or
a few of them very few of them bounce
back from the gold foil and he came up
with the idea that
because of this that an atom was mostly
empty space that's why most of the
particles went through now once that
bounce backwards were because they hit
the proton that's how he came up with
the idea that atoms have a nucleus in
them and that nucleus is governed by a
proton okay so if these particles bounce
back well then you can say well maybe
photons also bounce backwards but see
see we got a problem because if you know
here otherfor reached the wrong
conclusion he assumed he assumed or he
concluded that an atom is mostly empty
space because the alpha particles he
also did it with beta particles by the
way let me just show that real quick
what what I'm talking about
alpha particles beta particles you know
that's that's what they are now if a
particle essentially a helium atom two
protons and two neutrons and a beta
particle is just either an electron or a
positron a positive electron okay so
beta particles are smaller than the
alpha particles first of all and second
you can say that the alpha particle is
matter but the beta particle is well
yeah I guess an electron is matter when
it's a particle now when it's a wave
okay so that's essentially what what
Rutherford did he just threw these
particles out of gold foil and found out
some of them bounce but mostly went
through it so he said well if both of
them go through and only a few bounce
back the ones that bounce back hit the
proton the center doesn't you know the
nut right at the ass Center but all the
others went through because an atom is
mostly empty space that was his
conclusion and of course chapter 7 you
have a different explanation for the
same phenomenon for back scattering and
it shows that an atom is not mostly
empty space
it just has properties which mr.
Rutherford who just dealt with particles
did not consider in his
no in his evaluation so it's a long
story but all I'm saying there is a
different explanation for the same
phenomenon that Rutherford explained and
the rope model does offer this
alternative okay and again it's a long
story I'm not gonna deal with it here
outside the context that I'm trying to
explain right now
the other thing is you know if we go
back to particles we've got the problem
with a water sprinkler the water
sprinkler version of light you know if
if a photon is released by by the
electron jumping back and forth between
energy levels if it releases a photon
well and the photon is at discrete
particles none of those particles should
travel straight okay they should all
travel in curves like you have they
should travel like a water sprinkler
they're showing you know like the drops
coming out of a water sprinkler there
you have the Sun and the Sun emits
photons and every atom in the Sun emits
emits a photon and let's look at just a
single atom in the Sun it emits one
Photon
the atom is spinning and so is the Sun
the Sun is constantly spinning so the
next photon will travel not right behind
you know right behind the other one in a
straight line it'll travel in a curve
like a water sprinkler it'll travel you
know like I just showed a second ago
it'll travel more or less like this okay
because if the Sun is turning around you
know all those water droplets they're
not going to go in a straight line not
the ones coming out of what are the
nozzles for example and here we have you
know photons coming out of one atom they
cannot travel straight and so you know
the particle model cannot explain the
straightness of the rectilinear
propagation of light cannot explain that
okay let's see Martin did you ever get
to provide an answer in person to that
other inmate who asked you to prove the
non-existence of God Oh what you got
started in your quest yeah no I never
had
never got to answer that question
I just got sidetracked by physics at
that point never came back to religion
again with the traditional religion I
get into a different religion called
mathematical physics so no I never went
back the answer really to the question
is the one I had given them and that is
that you know the person who proposes
God he's the guy giving the presentation
he's the guy with a microphone he's
supposed to tell us that what God is and
second why he exists he cannot say well
here I am you know I propose God proved
to me I'm the speaker I'm the guy giving
the presentation proved to me that my
God doesn't exist no no you're the guy
who has to make its case you're the
prosecutor of the theory you're not the
defendant you're the prosecutor you're
the guy who's supposed to prosecute your
theory you're supposed to go out there
and try to convince people or explain to
them at least you know your your logic
your rationale
you can't later on say well you know I'm
I'm gonna say that angels exist front of
me that angels don't exist
I am I say that spirits exist proved to
me that spirits don't exist I say that
space-time exists prove to me that
space-time does not exist it doesn't
work that way and that's essentially the
answer to God so that's the answer I had
given them I never looked back that is
the correct answer I think there's no
other answer for that the guy who gave
him the presentation must justify his
assumptions you know you don't you don't
go out there and say because see the way
it works is you say let us assume that
God exists
okay no problem let us assume so I can
understand the theory and he says God is
this man with a magic wand fine no
problem and let us assume he exists no
problem you can at the end of your
presentations just say well prove to me
that my God doesn't exist I don't prove
because it's an assumption we conceded
the assumption to understand the theory
that's the that's the Meccan thats how
the scientific method works you provide
an assumption and so the person
understands
theory that you're going to explain with
that assumption you can't later on at
the end as part of your conclusion say
prove to me that my assumption is you
know doesn't exist my objects don't
exist it doesn't work that way anyways
the point that I'm trying to make that
you know the Rope can explain or justify
many of the properties of light
magnetism electricity the atom and the
workings of the atom and also of gravity
and it can do all of these where the
wave and the particle cannot but let's
forget about that
all I'm saying the soft conclusion as I
called it the mild conclusion is the
Rope should be considered side by side
with these other mechanisms or objects
okay and with that I'll see you next
time same time same station we'll see
you there bye bye